je ne peux pas vous dire encore il y
aura une décision collective collégiale
qui sera prise cet après-midi mais il y
a une chose qui est certaine c'est que
ce texte dans sa version de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale ne nous convient pas il ne
nous convient pas parce qu'il a
détricoté méthodiquement la version qui
était tout à fait convenable qui était
celle qui avait été obtenue par la
majorité de droite au Sénat elle ne nous
convient pas donc nous verrons bien s'il
y a une motion de rejet qui qui est
adoptée ou pas mais de toute
façon çap beaucoup immigration tel qu'il
est auourdjet on parler mais sur la
motion de rejet ça dépend beaucoup de
vous est-ce que vous souhaitez vous que
les députés les républicains la vote
encore une fois je suis député au
Parlement européen j'ai
Gén j'ai trop de respect pour les
institution trop de respect pour mes
collègues parlementaires de l'Assemblée
nationale pour décider à leur place ils
décideront eux-mêmes mais ce qui est
certain je vous le dis en tout cas c'est
que la version de la commission des lois
c'est celle qui est sur la table de
l'Assemblée nationale nous la rejetons
alors je vous pose la question TR est-ce
que si aujourd'hui vous étiez député
vous la voteriez vous cette mon mais on
peut le faire CIN fois si vous voulez
dis
juste je vous dire personnellement je
rejette la version qui est sur la table
de l'Assemblée nationale
compr pour une motion de rejet ou pour
un refus de vote du du texte à la fin ça
revient au même vous pouvez la rejeter
et et laisser le débat se faire en
séance et remodifier le texte en séance
mais avec une majorité de gauche ça ne
va pas fonctionner parce que Gérald
d'manin est un ministre de droite d'une
majorité de gauche Gérald daranin même
avec toute sa bonne volonté fait
semblant de vouloir prendre nos
amendements et en réalité il est
lui-même prisonnier d'une majorité de
gauche donc ce texte tel qu'il existe
actuellement doit être rejeté et je
déplore je déplore que l'assemblée
national et rejeter le projet de loi
constitutionnel qui avait été mis sur la
table par et qui permet de reprendre la
main en matière migratoire qui permet
qui permet d'imposer les plafonds
migratoires c'est-à-dire de choisir son
immigration et de s'imposer ainsi aux
traités européens et à la jurisprudence
européenne et par exemple à l'article 8
de la Convention européenne des droits
de l'homme qui énonce une automaticité
du regroupement familial si nous voulons
mais c'est ça qui
m'intéresse mais c'est
je vais vous dire pour cette non mais
juste pour vous nous dites il y aura une
décision collégiale est-ce que vous êtes
sûr qu'elle sera si collégiale que ça la
décision et que tout le monde sera sur
la même ligne dans votre groupe mais si
vous mettez 62 hommes et femmes ensemble
il y a toujours des sensibilités
différentes je crois qu'en revanche nous
sommes tous d'accord pour dire c'est
pour ça que j'insiste là-dessus ce matin
et que je préfère parler du fond que de
la forme et que de la procédure nous
sommes tous d'accordoup ch la LI
républain mais mais bien sûr mais euh
encore une fois comprenez bien parce que
ceux qui nous regardent
ils ne suivent pas tous les épisodes
parlementaires heure par heure ce qui
les intéresse c'est est-ce que le projet
de loi immigration voulue par le
gouvernement aura pour conséquence plus
d'immigration ou moins
d'immigration